I've got an update on the so called
remember this lady we a lot of people
became smitten with her the subway
soprano we called her listen to how she
its that note oh my gosh the hair is on
the back of my neck stand up when I hear
her so we told you about her earlier
this week she's a homeless woman her
name is Emily
zoom Orca she became an internet
sensation she's from Russia and she came
here years ago she was captured on video
singing Puccini in the Los Angeles
subway by a police officer well now
she's reportedly been offered a
recording contract Grammy nominated
music producer Joel diamond you go mr.
diamond reportedly hopes to make a
classical EDM which stands for
electronic dance music dance music me
crossover hit record for the Morka
meantime to go to goof only go further
may to GoFundMe campaign it's all mesh
they're together okay - GoFundMe
campaign - phrase it sold more than 93
thousand dollars for the homeless woman
she just says listen yeah she's very
touched by the outpouring of support of
course and she said she just can't wait
to get it in the studio and start
singing I'm very excited about this I'm
excited for it too it turns out well I
guess not homeless anymore can we say
she's resting peacefully tonight we
don't know where she is but I do think
she's off the streets I do think that
it's nice that so many people yeah yeah